Hello, everyone, and welcome back to the second
half of our tardigrade reproduction spectacular.
In our last episode, we got a very close look,
though I suppose all of our looks are pretty
close, at the various biological intimacies
exchanged by tardigrades as they mate.
Multiple males contended for the heart, or
at least the unfertilized eggs, of a female
tardigrade by poking endlessly at her exuvia.
It was really quite dramatic, and if you haven't
watched it yet, you should.
It’s great.
There’s poop.
But now, it is time for the thrilling conclusion
to all of that mating: the babies.
This tardigrade has been lugging her future
offspring in a sack made up of her exuvia,
which is her shedded exoskeleton.
Like a spare room that's been converted into
a baby nursery, the same exuvia that started
as the mother's own cuticle before it became
the site of courtship, has now undergone another
renovation to become a handy, portable egg
nursery.
The ways that tardigrades deal with their
eggs may look different for different species.
While this water bear carries her exuvia at
the end of her body, some species carry it
more towards the front.
Some don't lay eggs in exuvia at all, while
another species has been seen depositing their
eggs in the exuvia of water fleas.
Why our species has evolved or chosen this
method is unknown to us.
Maybe it allows her to provide them protection,
or perhaps she can ensure they hatch in the
best possible location this way.
We just don't know.
But we did very much want to observe this
mother-to-be.
And so for three days, we followed her, doing
our best to also take good care of her.
Now, the biggest concern was making sure she
wouldn't get too dry, so we had to keep her
away from the edges of the slide.
To do this we used only the most advanced
techniques: we poked her with the fine hair
from a brush to push her towards the more
watery regions of the slide.
We even set an alarm to remind us to add a
drop of water to the slide every four hours.
Yes, even at night.
That’s a lot of alarms.
Now, you might be thinking--aren't tardigrades
supposed to be the hardiest creatures on Earth?
Able to withstand extreme conditions, hypothetical
apocalypses, and maybe even crash landings
on the moon?
Surely they do not require this level of helicopter
parenting (or I guess it’s grandparenting?).
Well, we do care a lot for all of our microscopic
organisms, and so it could be that this watery
vigil is just an abundance of caution on our
part.
But we've seen with our own eyes that no matter
how tough tardigrades may be, the microcosmos
is tougher.
Sometimes things just...happen, and not in
the way you might hope.
You might remember this tardigrade from a
previous episode.
We were pretty excited about her because we
could see all of those eggs just ready to
be hatched.
But the mother was completely still.
She hadn't moved at all, which would usually
be worrisome.
But she wasn't decomposing, so we thought
maybe she was still alive, just biding the
time until her eggs hatched.
And so while she waited, so did we.
Gestation in tardigrades can vary quite a
bit, not just by species, but with temperature
and just plain old chance.
It generally takes a few days, but it can
take months.
We kept her in a humidity chamber and checked
in to make sure the coverslip wasn't crushing her.
But the inactive tardigrade never became active
again.
Eventually, her body did begin to decompose,
as did the eggs inside her.
And so, this tardigrade family was not meant
to be.
We don't know what killed this tardigrade,
but it's hard not to feel responsible for
the organisms we film.
Sure, they're unaware of our existence,
but they are in our care, and like the animals
and humans we come to feel connected to, it's
sad to be reminded that endings can come for
even the mightiest creatures among us, even
if they're also among the smallest.
That's why, when we later found the impending
tardigrade mother that started this episode,
we took so much care to keep her alive.
It was nerve-wracking because we didn't want
to lose another brood, hence the 4 hour alarms
and the brush hair.
So you might be able to imagine our combined
excitement and relief when after 4 days of
this intensive care, we saw a tardigrade cuticle
that was no longer full of eggs--it was full
of egg shells and baby tardigrades!
Now unfortunately, it turned out that getting
footage of the actual hatching during this
moment was challenging.
The eggs would roll around in the cuticle
while also being dragged by the mother.
But you can see the baby tardigrades clawing
their way through the mass of eggs.
Eventually though, the mother finally completely
shed her cuticle.
You can see it here, it almost looks like
a tardigrade ghost chasing behind her.
This moment was particularly fortuitous for
us because as the tardigrade rid herself of
the exuvia that had housed her future children,
one unhatched egg came out as well.
It's weird to look at this and realize that
in a few moments, out will come a tardigrade.
Just an oval with some lines in it, a formed
thing packed away.
That arrow-shaped thing that's pumping away
is the tardigrade's stylets, a part of their
mouth that pokes out when it comes time to
eat and it helps the tardigrade suction out
the meatiness of the microbes that it feeds
on.
But before they can get to eating, the stylets
have an important task: helping the baby tardigrade
get out of their shell.
After two hours of struggling, the stylets
of the tardigrade begin to move more repetitively
until finally, it's able to poke holes in
the egg.
These holes allow water into the egg, increasing
the pressure inside until the egg just pops
and out comes a little moss piglet.
And with it, a new generation is born, adding
to a lineage of mighty microscopic animals
stretching back hundreds of millions of years.
If you heard a sigh just then, it's a sigh
of relief and joy from all of us at the Microcosmos team.
When we set out to track and record a tardigrade
birth, we didn't know that it would lead to
both heartbreak and excitement.
But it's all worth it for this little buddy
among many.
We hope to see them all again, perhaps creating
their own brood.
But for now, paddle away, our little friend,
the whole microcosmos awaits.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
Journey to the Microcosmos is produced by
Complexly.
If you want to keep imagining the world complexly
with us, you can check out Animal Wonders,
a YouTube channel hosted by Jessi Knudsen
Castañeda.
Animal Wonders is an animal rescue and education
facility that cares for close to 100 exotic
animals and non-releasable wildlife.
Every week on the Animal Wonders YouTube channel,
Jessi features a different animal and shares
what it’s like to keep them happy and healthy.
Recently, Jessi and the Animal Wonders team
took in Tigli the arctic fox.
If you’d like to learn all about Tigli’s
story and find out how he’s getting along
with the other foxes at Animal Wonders, there’s
a link in the description to a video all about that.
And here is a list of all of the people who
support us on Patreon.
Thank you so much to all of them for allowing
us to go on this journey and allowing us to
take so many other people along with us.
You can be one of those people and get some
really cool perks,
just go and check out patreon.com/journeytomicro.
Thanks to our Master of Microscopes James
for all of his amazing work and skill.
If you’d like to see more of what he does,
you can check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you’d like to see more of what we
do, just go to youtube.com/microcosmos where
you can find our entire first season of videos
and also click on that subscribe button so
you can find a new video every single week.
Ok. Bye